on to vaccines now this is really a
great uh
decision that pfizer and moderna have
made
pfizer and moderna have turned down
donald trump's invitation to a
propaganda vaccine summit scheduled for
today at the white house
and i have to tell you seeing this makes
me more confident in these vaccines not
that i wasn't already confident but this
increases to me as a signal that pfizer
and moderna as the manufacturers of the
first two coronavirus vaccines expected
in the u.s very soon
they are staying away from political
optics when it comes to the vaccine
trump is doing by the time you listen to
today's show
he may already have done it a vaccine
summit
at the white house to take credit for
these vaccines
trump will be there pence will be there
there will be other private sector
executives there including people
involved
sort of in the logistics of the shipping
and distribution of these vaccines
it certainly is being interpreted as an
event
meant to pressure the fda to quickly
approve these vaccines it's a political
event to put political pressure on the
fda
and both pfizer and moderna have said no
thanks we're not going to go
we know that the fda commissioner
stephen hahn has been called to the
white house at least two times
almost like being called to the
principal's office to explain
why aren't you approving these vaccines
more quickly so we know that the white
house is very anxious to see that happen
so there's a few good things here first
of all
good for pfizer and moderna they are
developing a vaccine
they're going through the process for
approval they are opting out of this
political charade
and that makes me more confident that
they are doing things the right way now
cnbc
was saying the official reason that they
aren't participating
is that they have vaccine approval
pending before the fda
so that it would not be ethical or
appropriate for pfizer and moderna to
appear
with the fda at what is a political
propaganda event
moderna put out a statement very
carefully worded which said
we don't have an ideological objection
to being there
but when we learned the agenda of the
meeting
we realized our participation isn't
required
and that's such a narrowly and carefully
worded public relations statement that
it really doesn't change the
understanding of why they're not going
to be there for me
but the bottom line is the optics of the
vaccine manufacturer
and the regulatory agency that will be
deciding about that vaccine's approval
being there together at what is a
political dog and pony show
it wouldn't be good so they're making
the right decision secondly
the optics of attending
would fuel the idea that donald trump
had something to do with these vaccines
when in fact
he did not them not attending pfizer and
moderna
is also good for that reason although
trump's sycophants will think that this
is the trump vaccine
anyway and you know what i don't care if
it convinces them to get vaccinated they
can think whatever they want think
if you'll go and get the vaccine because
you believe it to be the trump vaccine
have added hoss we all benefit from you
going and getting vaccinated
but now and this is the really big
explosive story
we have learned that pfizer may have
extra reason not to attend which is that
we learned yesterday that over the
summer
pfizer went to the trump administration
and gave them an option to buy
and secure more doses of their vaccine
trump refused
and now donald trump is demanding more
production from pfizer
even though he turned down more doses
let's talk about that next